what's up guys welcome to my tutorial
series on web scraping so in this
tutorial we're just gonna do some really
basic web scraping we're just gonna
scrape one page and in this case it's
the IMDB top 25 or top 50 adventure
movies but before we get started I want
to have you guys download select your
gadget Chrome extension I'll have a link
to this in the description but
essentially it gives you the CSS tag for
different elements on web pages and
you're gonna need that in order to
actually web scrape those elements from
from the page then you can go ahead and
navigate to whatever site you're trying
to web scrape and we can start writing
some code and our so we're first gonna
load in the two libraries that we'll be
using our vest which is for the web
scraping part and deep wire which allows
us to do this cool thing called piping
which I'll explain in a bit but if you
don't have these libraries installed you
just need to run these two lines
installed out packages and then our vest
or a deep liar make sure that you do
those in quotes cool so we'll load in
those two libraries and then we are
gonna actually create a new variable for
our link so I'll go ahead and copy this
and we're also gonna write page equals
read HTML link now I'll explain what
this command does in a sec but
essentially it just gets the HTML code
from this web page awesome so from this
like I mentioned we're gonna scrape the
name the year the rating and the
synopsis we're first gonna start by
creating the name column so we're gonna
make a variable called name and that's
gonna use this HTML code that we just
fetched and it's gonna feed that into
the HTML nodes function and then this is
where the chrome selector gadget comes
in handy so we're gonna go back to our
page we're gonna click on this icon in
the top right that's actually the
selector gadget tool and now when we
move our mouse around the window you'll
see different things starting to
highlight so we just want to grab the
titles for now so we'll click on one of
the titles and you notice that a lot of
text turns yellow since we only want the
titles we need to deselect everything
that's not the title so in order to
deselect you just click again so I
clicked on a number of votes because
that was yellow and now it turns out red
and select a gadget really quickly
figured out that I only want the titles
so that's what it's highlighted for me
and I know that there are 50 of them on
this page and there's a 50 right here so
I know that that's the right number so
we should be good to go but you might be
in a situation where you need to
deselect multiple things and if that's
the case just just go ahead and keep
doing that great so once we get this tag
we can copy it to our clipboard and
paste it in our HTML notes function now
we just need to pipe that one result
into HTML text so I'll give you a quick
explanation of what these are best
commands do and also what this pipe
operator is in case you've never seen it
before
so the first our guts command that we're
using is read HTML and essentially what
it does is given a URL it gives you back
an HTML document or the source code for
that rather we're then calling the HTML
node functions with the CSS selector and
this will given the HTML source code
pull out the actual elements that we
want to grab but even after that you
have to call HTML text because there
will still be the the link tags for the
movies for example around the names of
the movies so HTML text will actually
parse the text from within those tags
and then the pipe operator is this
percent greater than percent it's part
of the deep wire library and essentially
it makes coding really easy and our if
you haven't used it before I'd highly
recommend using it all the time or
whenever you can but in this example if
you have a as a vector of one two three
and you call a pipe mean that's the same
thing as calling mean a so it takes
everything that's to the left of the
pipe it computes that and it takes the
result and passes it in as the first
argument to the function that's after
the pipe so pretty easy super useful
great so now that we've written the code
for the name column we can go ahead and
run this
and if I see what the output for name is
it looks pretty good it has all of our
movie titles cool so now I want to grab
the ear so we're gonna do something very
similar where we call HTML nodes and we
have to go back to Chrome clear our
selection from selector gadget and now I
just need to select the ears you'll see
that it also selected the number and I
don't want that so I'm gonna click there
and now it's selected something else and
I don't want that so click there and
there it's gotten all the years so copy
that tag plug it into HTML nodes and
grab the text if we run that line and
output the years that gives us exactly
what we want
we just perfect we just have two more
we're gonna grab the rating so again go
back to selector gadget make sure that
we get rid of the stuff we don't want
and we get our ratings grabber text and
then the last thing is getting the
synopses of all these movies so clicked
once for the synopsis deselect and there
we go
so it's synopsis pasted grab the text
cool so I know that the names in the
year is right I just want to confirm
that the rating and synopses are right
so let me go ahead and run those lines
reading looks good and synopsis also
looks good so I'd recommend just running
these lines as you um as you go ahead
and start there as you go ahead and do
your scraping because sometimes the tag
that selector gadget gives you isn't
always right and I'll actually address
this in a future tutorial how how you
can go about other ways of getting those
tags but just yeah I just go ahead and
keep debugging as you as you write your
code all right so now we have our four
variables and we're gonna treat these as
columns for our data frame
and in order to make that dataframe
we're just gonna call the data train
commands and plug in the name the year
the reading the synopsis and I'm also
gonna throw in another argument in there
called strings as factors and set that
to false I think by default this is true
and essentially what that does is it
makes when it's true it makes all of
your your columns into factors instead
of characters or numeric or whatever
else they should be so just watch out
for that we can run this now we can view
our movies data frame and you can see
just in a few lines we got hold the text
from our IMDB page into a data frame and
just the last thing I'll show you is how
do you what if you want to say this is a
CSV file it's super easy we're just
gonna set our working directory to our
source files and then write dot CSV
movies the variable name and then the
name of the file that we want it to be
called so movies dot CSV we can run that
and it looks like our movies dot CSV
file is generated just like we want so
that pretty much wraps up this tutorial
I'll definitely get more in depth into
future videos into the next videos in
this series will touch on how to go into
individual pages what happens if you
have multiple pages of results like in
this case there's a lot more than 50
movies there are a thousand of them so
what if we wanted to scrape all of them
and then again like what if select your
gadget doesn't give you the right CSS
tag what can you do about that so
definitely check out these videos if
you're interested and if you have any
feedback feel free to leave a comment
below but other than that thank you and
we'll see the next video
you